Charlotte tu es en train de traverser
toute la vallée de la Maurienne c'est
magnifique en direction de Bonneval tu
en prends plein les yeux j'ai
l'impression non c'est une barre
symbolique franchit lundi
17,01 degré de moyenne sur la terre
record de chaleur absolue battu hier
17,18 degrés on n'a jamais eu en moyenne
à la surface du globe une température
aussi élevée cette Français sur 10
assure ressentir le changement
climatique au quotidien selon un sondage
autoxat et pourtant il serait toujours
sur les vieux diesel montrer l'enquête
du journal Le Parisien la raison c'est
le prix des occasions et du litre de
gazole qui est à peu près 20 centimes
moins cher que celui d'essence ces
chiffres records sont issus de première
mesure d'un observatoire météorologique
américain qui recense et analyse les
températures dans le monde entier hier
dans de nombreuses régions du globe
comme on peut le voir en rouge sur cette
carte elles ont été bien plus élevées
que les normales de saison au Canada en
Russie en Afrique du Nord au
Moyen-Orient et même en Antarctique il
faut savoir que la météo alors on en
parle comme ça mais c'est que ça
influence toute notre vie tout le temps
même au niveau des élections je sais pas
si vous en souvenez quand il y a eu des
élections présidentielles je vous disais
s'il fait beau en général les gens
viennent plus voter moi je pensais que
c'était l'inverse et ben non si par
exemple on prend 3 degrés au niveau des
températures c'est 1% de moins
d'abstention ça joue à tous les niveaux
alors on a une profession aussi alors là
qui est météo sensible de dingue moi je
vois ici Marcel ce sont les comédiens
j'ai eu un moment de
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous savez le comédien quand
ils arrivent le mercredi bises il va
faire quel temps il va faire quel temps
parce que
c'est un acteur heureux bah oui
forcément puisque autre fréquentation
des salles quand il pleut et ben écoutez
voilà c'est plus 30 % la météo là en
revanche moi je vous fais peur
régulièrement ce que vous dites pas qui
fait pas beau chez nous parce que
regardez il suffit que on annonce de la
pluie au niveau des réservations c'est
moins 10 15% en revanche si on a du
soleil
j'ai un pouvoir de dingue on a
enregistré des records de température au
mois de juin particulièrement dans les
océans la battu des records de
température en Thaïlande au Vietnam en
Birmanie en Chine plus près de nous le
mois de juin 2023 et le mois le plus
chaud en Grande-Bretagne c'était
lunettes de vue que vous avez là ou pas
votre lumière est tellement épouvantable
[Rires]
c'est notre frigidaire du désert ça
rafraîchit l'eau on peut y mettre
jusqu'à 20 litres
je le remplis avec ce tuyau et en
quelques heures l'eau est fraîche
pour la fabriquer nous-mêmes on a trouvé
le cadavre de l'animal et on l'a
transformé en fontaine
[Musique]
le 8
le bidet c'est le billet
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais mal réglé mon bidet
c'est bizarre d'un coup je me sens
beaucoup plus frais une image insolite
des insectes envahissent New York et se
baladent depuis une semaine de Manhattan
à Brooklyn c'est hors de pucerons ne
sont pas dangereuses rassurent les
scientifiques mais ces minuscules
bestioles pourraient se multiplier très
vite et donc continuer à hanter les rues
en Nouvelle-Zélande une grande chaîne de
télévision s'est fait taper sur les
doigts par le gendarme de l'audiovisuel
néo-zélandais leur CSA pour avoir
diffusé à une heure où les enfants
regardent encore la télé un documentaire
animalier avec une scène d'accouplement
de dauphins or comment ça coupe le les
dauphins et bien on voit plusieurs
beaucoup de mal qui entourent une
femelle isolée de force et qui vont
s'accoupler avec elle chacun à leur tour
plusieurs fois hier il y a un juge un
juge un juge qui a été qui a eu du
sursis
a été réduite en appel il vendait sa
fille sur internet pour des plaisirs
sexy il a eu du sursis bordel de merde
pour une canette de Red B
l mais dans quel monde on vit mais dans
quel monde on vit un moment on voit même
un pénis de dauphin dans l'image les
enfants ne peuvent pas regarder ça tout
seul a dit le gendarme de la télévision
il fallait mettre au moins un
avertissement de type certaines scènes
peuvent choquer ce à quoi les
réalisateurs de ce documentaire
animalier ont répondu quelque chose de
très intelligent il ne faut pas juger
cette scène avec notre sensibilité
d'humain nous on voit clairement un viol
en réunion on trouve ça horrible mais la
nature n'est pas morale elle n'est pas
bonne elle n'est pas mauvaise elle est
et il s'agit de comprendre ce qui se
passe impossible de ne pas être attendri
par sa réaction presque humaine
si vanille a 28 ans s'émerveillent
autant c'est qu'elle voit le ciel pour
la première fois après une vie en
captivité des années enfermée dans une
cage sans même voir la lumière du jour
ce chimpanzé de laboratoire retrouve
soudainement la liberté celle de marcher
en pleine nature là encore comme un
homme une nouvelle vie grâce au
sanctuaire sève de James qui vient au
secours de plus de 200 primates en leur
offrant un refuge et des soins en
Floride Thomas que vous êtes capable de
manger une tarte au citron sans les
mains le plus rapidement possible oui
c'est ce qu'on tenté de faire 25
américains hier lors du championnat
mondial de dégustation de tarte au
citron vert c'est Floride le gagnant a
relevé le défi en seulement trois
minutes et 35 secondes
bonne question vous avez jamais vu
Popeye si là là en images mais le nom
d'accord donc en images vous l'auriez
appelé comment le gars
[Musique]
Monsieur Propre Monsieur Propre
évidemment non ça c'est moi ça
c'est la c'est quoi
[Musique]
regardez c'est ce qui s'appelle une
belle sortie de route ça se passe à
Atlanta cette marathonienne était à deux
doigts de la victoire mais elle s'est
trompée de voix
qui lui a coûté cher dans tous les sens
du terme puisqu'on arrive en 3e elle a
remporté que 3000 dollars alors qu'elle
aurait pu en gagner 10000 si elle
n'avait pas pris la tangente
15 secondes vite
[Musique]